j'ai reçu une lettre d'un abonné ça ne
veut se faire plaisir d'accord il ya
tout ça aussi d'accord j'appelais
j'avais pas ga pas tilté
[Musique]
évidemment pile poil le jour au jour une
vidéo je suis complètement malade j'ai
donc actuellement la voix de garou du
mouton de petites coques d'iphone up
petite toque bien propre merci mon pote
elle va parfaitement mon portable et
apparemment elle protège bien on a du
gâteau fin on a dit gâteau maintenant
j'ai google a je pense que dès que j'ai
ramené une map chez moi je perds et tu
veux un gâteau je donne la fredzone
alors ça c'est extrêmement beau je
suppose que la personne qui a fait ça
est complètement en maternelle dont le
talent est présent un faux chèque d'un
million d'euros ouais c'était plaisir le
gars qui d'astuces soif autant que ce
soit des grosses sommes j'ai quand même
essayé d'en encaisser parce que ça lui
ta tête et drôle mais pas toi
non c'est une blague tout est nul chez
toi j'ai [ __ ] un truc c'est la sartec
l'équipe donc du maquillage pour
représenter cette équipe de ok que sont
les boxers je suis actuellement un
indien bon les mecs le mug a pas tenu le
mug feu ne fonctionne plus salut normal
je m'appelle guillerme je suis un grand
fan et je voulais te dire que tu es le
meilleur youtuber merci mon pote
le gars tapé à l'ordinateur quoi le mec
et il est sérieux quoi oui oui je savais
pour rien j'appuie pour rien
oh [ __ ] à montchat ressemble à cergy
sauf que elle est née avec une petite
queue bon alors bon le noeud qu'une
boutique pe s'est pas c'est pas grave un
message à tous les chats qu'on est petit
que c'est pas grave d'accord et pareil
pour les hommes trop stylé la petite
poupée avec un max de bouclettes elle
est vachement bien faite et bien que
vous nous arrêtent cadeaux team a coûté
cher donc plus en bon usage signé enzo
la racaille de la stricte
voilà c'est la racaille de la stricte
bonjour théophile c'est norman thavaud
l'appareil [ __ ] légende c'est quoi ils
prennent du temps qu'on perd de très
très beaux dessins
merci d'avoir investi du temps dans ce
dessein un euro à 1 euro on peut se
prendre un caddie à leclerc un caillou
le mec m'offre un caillou et coûteux
je vais mettre dans mon jardin adam mais
dans les graviers quoi pour tes jolies
cern du génial une crème anti cernes
c'est mieux ou pas et bizerte alliés
alors au nom n'est déçu n'a pas d'iphone
des petites cartes pokémon avec des
youtuber dessus et à la carte mr vie et
la carte cortex draps il est clair une
bombe de peinture assez larnack dicko
[ __ ] mais où l'esprit de la fête
je me régale à vos cadeaux sarah et
bénédicte merci les filles pour cette
casquette bits
ah ouais un petit cola jeu trop stylé
qu'une vidéo de dents à wave vous aimez
vraiment le monde de l'habitat les
claques d'antoine fameux c'est pas fort
ça salut brice c'est normal le mec s'en
fout merci pour ta lettre tu m'as envoyé
une lettre n'est ce pas mais un dessin
et ben je te remercie beaucoup
c'est cool merci mon pote au jeu trop
mignon merci brice
après tout avoir un orgasme
juste hâtif ouais ce biscuit nuls fort
est c'est quoi dès que j'ai arrêté des
gens je me la péter avec mes gâteaux
faut je hurle à mes vermine
c'est extrêmement bien réalisé c'est
black and white l'est luigi babe des
lunettes décapsuleur y est
et en plus tu peux le faire avec deux
bouteilles un petit bracelet fou avec en
plus derrière un petit norman dessinée
trop mignon la puissance on m'a offert
un certificat d'adoption d'un corail
genre un truc officiel je participe à la
protection de la planète sans avoir rien
fait du tout alors elles sont vraies ou
fausses et la filiale génial ce mot en
tout cas je continue à ouvrir vos petits
papiers ça me fait hyper plaisir je ne
montre pas tous à la caméra parfois
c'est tout simple mais ça va droit au
coeur tuer les troncs de ma vie la
matière fécale du bonheur si un jour je
te vois tu illuminera mon caca norman
veux tu m'épouser
peut-être un jour dans le futur lointain
un daphné qui est d'ailleurs le prénom
de ma soeur voilà donc c'est c'est une
double gênant st bonjour norman cela
fait longtemps que je t'observe par la
fenêtre de sa cuisine
je vais rester anonyme bonjour personne
anonyme oui bonjour c'est normal ça va
[Musique]
ce dessin est très très beau vraiment
très très beau j'aime tout une serviette
hygiénique
bon bah je l'utiliserai quand j'aurai
mes règles à une d'être un petit peu
plus officiel facture edf annonce assez
ça c'est pas j'ai absolument tout ouvert
toutes les lettres tous les colis j'ai
tout regardé c'est vrai david ou pas
voilà j'ai fini mon déballage de lettres
et colis
on a passé la journée dessus merci
vraiment à toutes et à tous pour toutes
nos petites attentions toutes vos
lettres
vos messages on a vraiment tout regarder
ça m'a fait extrêmement plaisir ça me
donne encore plus envie de continuer
mais vidéo j'étais un peu moins présent
2016 parce que j'ai complètement fini la
tournée de spectacles qui est désormais
va terminer en 2017 je vais pouvoir me
concentrer à nouveau sur les vidéos donc
pour en faire un peu plus ça c'est cool
je vous souhaite de très bonnes fêtes de
fin d'année mettez un petit pouce en
l'air si vous avez qui fait et on se
revoit très bientôt les amis
[Musique]
à